today I'm here to suggest that we tear
this mother down the mother in question
is infrastructure specifically highways
one of the problems with the limited
lifespan that human beings have is that
we tend to think that the things that
exist when we're born are things that
have always been there and they're
things that always will be there so you
and I will probably never see the fall
of a city right we will see disasters
sure but we tend to think of cities as
places that just build more if we
implode a casino on the Las Vegas Strip
you build a new casino you build more
roads and skyscrapers and bus ways and
anything else that makes that makes the
furniture of a town right but that's an
illusion when you drive on a highway
especially when the cuts through a city
it's hard to remember that it's
something that probably isn't more than
50 years old and what that means is that
there was something that was there
before that right when you're on a
highway there was a time when that
highway wasn't there and below it was
maybe a street maybe a tree-lined street
maybe there were shops on it right the
city looked different that thing is not
permanent it's not forever so what I
want to suggest is that there are some
of these things that you can actually
get rid of now there's precedent for
this here in San Francisco after an
earthquake we took down the Embarcadero
Freeway I say we like I had something to
do with that I didn't they took down the
Embarcadero Freeway and produced what
turned out to be one of the most popular
public spaces in the city right on the
water in Boston they put the central
artery freeway underground it was called
the Big Dig it was hugely over-budget
and had all kinds of problems but
eventually end up with this kind of
green through the city and made a
beautiful part of town and as somebody
who used to dodge traffic on the central
artery to try to get from Haymarket to
the North End I was very thankful it's a
beautiful thing may your same to me but
wait what about the traffic right
because you think that the reason you
build highways is to reduce traffic the
fact is that doesn't happen when you
build a highway you actually increase
traffic you build more road space more
people start to drive but more
importantly even if you are doing some
reduction in traffic and even if you are
helping people get from one place more
efficiently to another you're also
killing whatever's beneath that freeway
you produced what's called in urban
planning a border vacuum nobody wants to
have any houses or shops or anything
alongside a freeway because it's high up
or it's low down in the ground and it
causes problems with shade and it's loud
so you end up killing everything to the
side of that cuts through community and
it kills stuff right through the middle
of that community divides both sides so
that's why I'm interested in a project
called highways two boulevards every
couple years these guys release a report
called freeways without futures and they
name some of the highways that they
think are candidates to tear down so
they have identified in the last one
just came out earlier this year places
like the Claiborne overpass in New
Orleans the Sheridan Expressway in the
Bronx one of my favorites actually is
i-70 cuts the city of st. Louis off from
the st. Louis Arch city arch there's a
highway along the river from Louisville
there's one along the water in Seattle
and some of them are actually along the
way to being taken down the cities have
various plans in place to try to get rid
of them the really fascinating thing
about a lot of the highways on this list
is how many of them cut through what
were formerly vibrant african-american
communities back in 50s and 60s a lot of
urban planners saw those communities as
places that were subject to blight right
and that the way to to renew them was to
build a highway through them but what
they ended up doing of course was
killing anything that was below those
highways and in cutting a line right
through them which did more economic
damage but we have an opportunity here
we have an opportunity to start taking
down some of the highways that don't get
used or in the wrong place
what would fall down in the next
earthquake think about it this way next
time you're driving on one of these
highways next time you're driving on a
highway that cuts through your city look
at the architecture on either side of it
because it'll probably match and imagine
that the two sides of that road were
actually a neighborhood once imagine
that instead of the highway you were
driving on there could be a light rail
line or bus ways or a tree line Street
with shops that you would have a place
that people could come together instead
of eight lanes of uncrossable traffic
cutting the place in half
you